[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan I'm censored tonight
shocking new poll so that young people
are abandoning the monarchy in droves so
how do the Royals win them back could
them suing Prince Harry for invading
their privacy be a good place to start
or debate
damning Boris Johnson biography of one
of Britain's eminent historians please
bear the shambles of his Premiership was
he Britain's worst ever leader
and as the oldest president in US
history gears up for another White House
run will debate aging politicians with a
man who thinks he could become the
youngest president in American history
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored next week's coronation of
King Charles will be a global spectacle
tens of millions will be watching as
Charles is crowned in a ceremony steeped
in a thousand years of Regal history but
judging by the headlines this week the
monarchist problems lie not in the past
but the future a shocking new poll says
78 of Britain's young people don't care
about the monarchy almost 40 percent of
them would even prefer an elected head
of state and actually who can blame them
for having a dim view of the royal
family or the monarchy given that two of
our most famous young Royals have waged
a three-year war on the institution they
weaponized the culture of validation for
victimhood and convinced a generation of
young people the monarchies and
Antiquated evil institution unless on a
fortnight before the biggest day in the
monarchy's recent history there again
out in force making sure the headlines
are all about them
our next speaker has an unmatched eye
for a good photograph I've experienced
his talent firsthand as he has captured
many meaningful milestones for me and my
family as Sean retiring Megan ostensibly
introducing a photographer friend at a
taught this week but of course I'm
subtly debuting a new look that
apparently we're told is more Paltrow
than princess either way we haven't seen
her since Harry's acidic Memoir pumped
416 pages of poisoning to the Royal
debate so why now well I think we can
guess right well I did this week we were
treated to well I don't know what you
call these pictures but we're supposed
to believe these are surprised that you
can Duchess at a basketball game in La
it's the Lakers I was there myself two
weeks ago and trust me you don't get
caught unawares if you're a famous
person at the Lakers they tell you in
advance the cameras will be on you do
you mind if they use you
yeah they knew
now about the same time here 5 a.m
Britain Prince William was laying
flowers at an Anzac Day Dawn service so
the message from California is clear you
can dress up in your dusty robes and
part through ancient rituals for
anti-politicians but we're the real
Royals We're Young we're spontaneous
we're free
and of course Prince Harry has launched
another privacy shattering projectile at
his family newspaper front pages have
plastered with details of a private
settlement let's emphasize that again a
private settlement by Prince William his
brother the details of which have only
become public because Harry has chosen
to invade his brother's privacy and tell
everybody even on the eve of the
coronation he's chosen to cause deep
embarrassment and potential harm to his
family
Harry's book of mistakes are Netflix
documentary Unleashed unprecedented
volumes of private secret intimate
details about Royal conversations into
the public domain for breathtaking pots
of cash the reality is that the biggest
and most ruthless Invader of Royal
privacy however in the monarchy's
history
is Harry
maybe it's time the royal family sued
Harry for invading their privacy
because the damage that these two are
doing is becoming very clear protest is
chanting not my king trying to disrupt a
visit by the king and queen to Liverpool
today
[Applause]
but and it's a really good but this
there's some hope
look at what these school children did
who were there they had other ideas
[Applause]
I love it that's the future surely now
joining me now is the host of The Big
Fish podcast Benson Matthews and Alex
O'Connor who is the host of the within
reason podcast and is an anti-modicist
plus writer and commentator Larissa
Kennedy well welcome to all of you so
Spencer you I mean you're related
to the royal family
um your brother's married to Pippa
Middleton who's obviously Kate says so
let's get out the way so you're not a
completely impartial Observer but you're
a monarchist like me you believe in the
Royal Family
this poll about young people
what do you make of it
um well I suppose it's it's it's a high
it's a high number of people who are
claiming not to care it's not a high
number of people who are claiming they
would want something else what is the
number do you know of people who would
prefer the alternative about 40
indicated they may not be opposed to
having some form of republic or
president whatever yeah I mean which is
exactly I mean the alternative would be
to have an elected head of state which
is that's what you would prefer is it
yeah you describe you mentioned earlier
that the the poll is shocking and said
that some people would even prefer an
elected head of state as if this is some
kind of radical idea what it is for this
country I don't think it's a surprise
that young people in this country are
quite mystified by this bizarre relic of
our Constitution that still relies on
the notion that hereditary political
office is legitimate is a legitimate
institution do you think they've looked
at for example the Premiership of Boris
Johnson and Liz truss over here or
Donald Trump in America thought you know
what we need get rid of the stable royal
family of the head of our country let's
go for a Boris and a Dom you think
people have done that in this country
well unfortunately that's what British
people actually think about elected
officials in other words be careful what
you wish for we have they're not elected
no they're no real executive power but
what they do provide in my in my
estimation they provide us with
something unique now when King Charles
gets current crowned at the coronation
in a week and a half's time the whole
world will watch and they will see our
country at its best doing more very few
places can do the pomp the pageantry the
military procession and it's something
to make us all feel proud what's wrong
with that well nothing but they did it
on my time I I don't see why you're done
tourism pays for it tourism look if it
were true that this money is essentially
going to pay for itself then why is it
that the government and uh and the King
felt it necessary to say that this would
be a service that had value for the
taxpayer why are the taxpayers are even
involved at all no why can't the right
gets the money and pay themselves get
some money back from tourism that's the
point yeah so the the net cost of the
royal family is a positive they don't
cost us anything so that argument never
watches with me because they actually
bring more than they cost so then you're
down to I don't like the fact these
people are privileged and live in
palaces and so on but they perform
hundreds of Duties a year I mean you
know this better than anyone and about
the amount no matter what let's let's
just bring uh Spencer back in you know
better than anybody no matter what they
all do right and they work hard well
just to be clear I'm not you know you
know I don't I can't speak from you know
for them but you're aware of the work
they do as an observer
um they're a very hard-working family
that symbolize patriotism
you know in this country and you know
the majority of them have dedicated
their entire lives to to service to to
to help Britain you know they they
that's that's all they really try to do
are often told that we don't really have
a good alternative to monarchy in this
country but I feel like we're already
living it I'm told on the one hand when
I complain about the illegitimate
influence that the monarchy has over the
politics of this country that they don't
really have any power at all they don't
really do anything they cut a few
ribbons here and there except for the
legal and tax exemptions that they have
the influence over the Prime Minister
perhaps this is true you're missing that
you're making the point maybe they
really don't have the power but you're
missing you're missing it no you're the
same token but somehow if I therefore
suggest that we should get rid of them
all together now you're thinking how
integral to the upkeep of the political
system no they're not royalist seems to
want to have the no no there is I don't
argue I don't argue that all that is
ceremonial all that stuff is ceremonial
to me they don't have an executive power
they don't make the laws that we that we
abide and live by what they provide and
we saw this clearly in the covid
pandemic when the queen went on national
television and acted like a national
comfort blanket they are there as a
constant above all the political Freight
and turmoil and when we have the big
Royal events there are millions and tens
of millions around the world who look at
our country in a favorable light and you
cannot calculate to me that value just
in what you think it costs to put them
in palaces and things because the value
in my view if you take it in totality
outweighs that and that's where their
value lies to me let me bring in Larissa
who's been listening patiently so you're
a young woman what do you think of the
royal family are you violently opposed
to them
I think it's not necessarily important
to dwell on my personal opinion but
looking at the statistic that you've
shared there I think it's interesting
that you know in the in the video prior
there's bringing in Harry and Megan into
this is bringing all sorts into this
when really young people not caring
about the royal family is because young
people have so much to care about right
now we care about the intergenerational
uh economic gap between uh those who
have come before us and being a
generation that may not do a better than
those uh prior we care about uh climate
breakdown and the fact that we may not
even have a planet uh to have Royals on
we care about the housing crisis we care
about the cost of living crisis there is
not space within the Overton Windows to
then discuss the fact that you know is
the are these pompous explains of excess
displays of excess rather an insult to
the widening gap between rich and poor
and the poorest in our society to even
question this is seen as hating written
when really it's about wanting the best
for everyone in Britain so I do struggle
with this idea that oh there are certain
things that have happened recently that
have caused young people uh to move away
from liking the royal family when really
is that we're not steeped in all of the
Nostalgia uh that I think yeah except
that except that I would argue this
right we've become a far more
Multicultural Society than we were say
30 40 years ago and there's no doubt
that in the polling for example on Megan
and Harry young people tend to feel
sympathy and believe what they're saying
about the royal family older people over
40 don't I mean the polls are very clear
and very split and my argument would be
that their allegations in particular
about racism in the royal family and
kallus disregards the mental health and
so on which were pushed very hard and
now seem to be a massive Retreat that
those allegations caused enormous damage
with young people particularly perhaps
young non-white people in Britain who
believe they're all family because
Meghan Markle said they were for a bunch
of races
I was going to ask you if that was a dog
whistle but you actually just explicitly
said that yourself so you are left
believe you believe that because there
are black and brown young people in the
country they hate the way the UK
functions is that what is that your art
did I they hate what
they hate the way that the UK functions
with the royal family is that is that
the person sorry you've missed you've
obviously Miss heard me before you throw
phrases like dog whistle before you
throw a phrases like dog whistle around
maybe listen to what I actually say what
I said what I said was what I said was
young people in the polling tend to be a
lot more sympathetic and a lot more
believing of the allegations of racism
by Meghan Markle and Prince Harry
against the royal family and that may be
one of the explanations why they are in
favor of perhaps getting rid of the
monarchy altogether so in my view it's
been damaging what Megan and Harry have
said and now they're backtracking from
what they said so they're never meant to
say there's any racism but actually we
all heard what they said and it caused
damage that's not a dog whistle I'm just
revealing facts
he's not a dog person it's an explicit
statement
what do you think I'm saying
the implication that black and brown
young people are the reason that 80 of
young people don't care about the money
I didn't say that
I didn't say that I said one of the
reasons why young people may not have a
good feeling about the monarchy is
because of the allegations not just
about racism but also about mental
health so you've got to listen to what
I'm saying before throwing around
phrases like dog whistles otherwise
otherwise you can jump to rather
extraordinary conclusions and make
rather bizarre allegations
I'm listening to what you're saying and
I also know the links that you are
hoping that listeners will create so I'm
just I'm just being real about it as you
like we are not though I you'll be I'm
afraid I'm afraid Larissa what you're
not being is real because the viewers
can actually hear what we're saying so
you're here which is that young people
are not only I think separately from
talking about Megan Harry I don't think
it has anything to do with that
I think they're looking at countries
like Barbados perhaps who are distancing
themselves from the monarchy and it
gives us a fresh opportunity to actually
discuss the history of monarchy not with
a lens that is riddled with Nostalgia
but critically and that is to say that
yes much has been achieved but at what
expense and there are lots of young
people and students who support
campaigns around reparations around
decolonization and so to do that and at
the same time to not have a critical
lens towards monarchy is on incongruent
it doesn't make any sense so I think
it's really important that we're seeing
that young people's opinions and
particularly
um young people who are criticizing
money monarchy isn't about recent events
it's about a historical analysis all
right I don't agree with you about it
not being connected but I I'm sure it's
partly both
um Spencer you do a great podcast I've
been on it
he talked a lot about Mental Health on
that you talked about all that yourself
do young people just look at all this
stuff through a different lens to people
of my age am I young people you're sort
of in the middle aren't that I'm 34
years old you're nearly middle age so
you know but but what's your general
sense about how Generations but I mean
it's just a generational thing do older
people have a different view of the
royal family and monarchy to young
people partly because of things like
that
um I I suppose I mean most of my guests
on big fish are
um are slightly older
um and and you know typically they've
had very interesting stories of how they
Rose to be successful and lots of that
has come through hardship and failure
and it's how they've navigated
um you know treacherous and difficult
times to become who they've become
um you know I I can't really speak to
the mental health of the the younger
generation but I certainly feel
um things might be a bit softer nowadays
actually yes in a way I think that is
what I'm I'm getting at really and I you
know I don't want to always bring these
Royal debates back to Megan and Harry
but part of my problem with what they
did is they weaponized things like
racism and mental health and it caused a
lot of damage to the reputation of the
Royals not just here but abroad and I
think I mean just to bring you back in
Alex
there's no doubt in my mind that has
contributed to young people and
particularly I suspect younger people of
color in this country who have brought
in perhaps two by believing what they've
been hearing that their royal family has
a group of racists amongst them and
that's not going to make you like an
institution it's going to make you want
to get rid of it sure well I I wouldn't
know there are a few things I find less
interesting in this world than the
sort of Private Affairs of Harry and
Megan or indeed public affairs of them
either but the problems with the
monarchy predate these two individuals I
mean there are plenty of ways to respond
to what you were saying earlier to
engender National spirit and but rest
the economy that don't involve
subscription to a hereditary a
controversial hereditary Dynasty whose
right to rule is still if I might be
allowed to remind you officially
legitimized by the authority of an
Anglican God that doesn't exist
I I'm sorry I just can't take this
seriously I understand you are the
heaviest anti-monica I understand why
they have to keep up with the crowns and
the caves without these who are these
people nothing more than 10 minutes
to tell me how this country should be
right I think why do you have more
qualification a person needs to
criticize the head of state is citizenry
within that head of within that state
I'd be quite concerned if you disagreed
with that I think that look with what if
you thought that you require more of a
of a of a reason to criticize your head
of state than just being supposedly a
subject to that head of state I mean at
the moment somebody claims the right to
rule over me by birth rate I think I
sort of automatically adopt the right to
criticize them too I'm not the one who
just to be clear you'd rather be ruled
by Boris Johnson I'm not the one who
records would you rather be ruled by
Boris Johnson I'd rather have an elected
head of state yes yeah like Boris
Johnson I'd much rather you see the
problem with
stability in in the royal family in the
sense that they are have always been
there and kind of you know if they do
continue we'll always be there whereas
politicians kind of come and go yeah and
politicians you know are in in one
minute and then somebody does something
and all of a sudden they're ousted and
also it's typically you'll always have
kind of 50 of the country that dislikes
any particular kind of head of state you
know and so aren't the figures just on
paper for the royal family better than
any than any politician in history
perhaps but aren't you traveled by the
incessant referral to these people as
highness and Majesty highness is a
relative I'll tell you what I'm more
offended by minuses
let me tell you I'm more offended by
calling Boris Johnson the right
honorable gentleman
we could probably do with getting all
right so when it comes to titles that
gives me more of a problem than calling
Charles King anyway gotta leave it there
we're going to debate the right
honorable Boris Johnson in the next
segment thank you both very much Steve
for coming in and you Larissa thank you
with your dog whistles I appreciate that
on Saturday next is Boris Johnson the
worst leader in modern history
discussing that next Mr Anthony Selden
the historian and author of a bombshell
book about Johnson's pretty awful time
in number 10.
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speech writers here but we do and
I promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it we're
talking about it Piers Morgan uncensored
Monday to Thursday at 8pm on talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook just over six
months as British sunnak became prime
minister and tried to restore some order
after the disastrous rains of wet
legislaus truss and Boris Calamity
Johnson or Johnson's three tumultuous
years in Downing Street have now been
serialized in a new book which includes
having no planned surprise surprise when
the UK voted for brexit and describing
herself to a number 10 advisor again no
surprise as the fuhrer so it's Boris
Johnson one of the worst if not the
worst leaders not just this country but
the modern world has ever seen wolf
joining me now as the author of the book
Johnson at number 10 the Inside Story
Sir Anthony Selden also joined by talk
to me contributor Esther Krakow on The
Daily mirrors Associated Kevin McGuire
well Sir Anthony great to see you
um how you managed to churn out these
weighty tomes on our leaders is beyond
me given the extra work you do in your
day jobs
um but you do and history three is the
beneficiary of this so a straight a
simple question in the pantheon of prime
ministers has there ever been a worse
one than Boris Johnson
well it's difficult uh Piers to say
because Prime Ministers uh like
footballers that they're in different
eras uh with different uh worlds of
operation but I think we can say that in
the last 100 years no prime minister has
so underperformed as Boris Johnson and
it's such a weighty time he he made
brexit happen it's it's highly debatable
whether Britain would have voted uh in
favor of brexit at the referendum for
better or worse they voted uh with a
majority to come out uh he made it
happen and he got brexit through
Parliament but he didn't have a plan
I just want to read an extract from the
book I mean this is unbelievable John
Summers is the Knight of the brexit vote
Johnson was finding it hard to think
straight he went up all night watching
the television as Islington home only
towards Dawn did he realize vote Lee
would actually she win oh bleep he said
we've got no plan we haven't thought
about it I didn't think it would happen
holy crap what will we do this is
unbelievable this is the guy who drove
brexit admitting he didn't think it
would happen and he had no plan and
guess what it turned out he didn't have
a plan
well he didn't have a plan and neither
did Dominic Cummings who was the other
key person who made it happen look there
are a lot of very good reasons for doing
brexit and I think that uh brexiteers
and non-brexiteers uh have a right to
feel aggrieved that there wasn't
something uh really worked out so that
the benefits and there are real benefits
of coming out of the EU that they
weren't really quickly seized upon and
we've lost a lot of time and uh part of
the reason why uh there is a cost of
living crisis at the moment and business
is finding it hard to secure alternative
markets outside the EU is because not
enough work was put in and frankly
blaming other people which is what uh
ministers tend to do isn't good enough I
mean they were there on the bridge at
the time particularly uh the captain
Boris Johnson and first mate uh Dominic
Cummings and they needed to have done
better but it wasn't just piers uh no
plan for brexit there wasn't a plan for
running the country either although
what's extraordinary is the delusion of
Boris Johnson there's another extract
here when he talks about where he's
quoted as saying I'm meant to be in
control he says after being increasingly
troubled by being bypassed by AIDS I am
the fuhrer he says I'm the king who
takes the decisions I mean these are
extraordinary comments by somebody who's
a British prime minister likening
himself in language to Adolf Hitler
well I think it's extraordinary and I
think that it was something he always
wanted and he had some of the real
attributes that you need to be a great
prime minister I mean he was hugely
captivating uh when he was speaking when
he was in a room everyone wanted to be
with him he had a great gift of optimism
we did see uh good things uh from him he
was I think uh very good communicating
with the nation during covid at his best
he did well during the Ukraine
crisis leading uh the fight uh against
um Russia uh showing great courage uh he
had it within him but look every great
prime minister appears has to have a
great team around them and he disparaged
his cabinet didn't appoint the best
people appointed people some who were
transparently not up to it
um he made it cleared a cabinet that he
had no time for them at all and to his
team rather than the people who really
know their way around Whitehall and
Westminster who know what the job is who
can support the Prime Minister he sat
them or failed to stand up to Dominic
Cummings when he was saying well that's
true and he also I'm going to say his
best team right he also comes across as
just a Serial liar somebody where you
just cannot really believe much that
comes out of his mouth
well
um uh one person who worked closely with
him said this is tough uh because he
lies morning noon and night uh so
Raymond Newell co-author and I uh
ourselves uh what we say is he had a
curious relationship with the truth he
had his own vision of what the truth was
he himself uh didn't think that he was a
liar but people around him found it
extraordinarily difficult uh to know
what he really thought uh and he kept
changing his mind uh not the least when
uh the latest person had been in the
room with him and that happens when you
come into being prime minister without
any
um clear ideology like uh Sacha had or a
sense of uh the party he didn't like the
conservative party he didn't like
Parliament didn't like cabinet didn't
like the EU didn't like universities
didn't like intellectuals uh it was very
clear what he disliked but very unclear
what he liked he had let's remember
being a successful pretty successful
um uh uh mayor of London at City Hall
and there he was a much more inclusive
figure and he also had a really good
quality of people around him yeah the
leader is only as effective as the team
I think you fit in Manila
yeah and also he had Cummings and he had
Carrie Johnson he's now wife and the
rules at each other's throats with their
different camps and it was all
completely divisive and dysfunctional I
certainly thank you very much indeed
it's a compellingly awful book and I
mean that as a compliment it's
compelling and brilliantly written it's
just awful in terms of confirming all my
worst suspicions about Boris Jones
albeit is a complex character but it's a
fascinating read as always so thank you
very much indeed I want to bring in
um Kevin and Ernesto here it really it
lives down to every expectation this
book but just in really grotesque detail
as Sir Anthony always finds with his
with his history he comes out very badly
Boris from us yeah I think history will
judge him really badly Ukraine is the
one thing I think he really got right
yeah but there he gets an 80 seat
majority he throws it away because it
used to he emphasized the calling
conservative he was like a snake oil
salesman he caught a moment he didn't
really believe in brexit himself it was
a form of him getting promotion which it
worked he went to number 10 is he the
worst prime minister last hundred years
um I noticed uh he's a very diplomatic
you said he under performed yeah and I
think I look back Eden was per 55 57 so
his uh crisis Liz trust was terrible but
very short lived I think David Cameron
would go down badly because he lost
Europe in a referendum he didn't want
but I think Johnson you go through it
even on even on Covert look he was he
was breaking the law himself
lecturing everybody I mean he may be
communicating well from the pony but he
wasn't he wasn't practicing what he
preached I think he will be the worst
Johnson for two reasons he was never
meant to be a leader because he's not a
leader he doesn't have the Integrity to
be a leader but also because he had no
ideological coherence to anything that
he did because you would read his pieces
that he used to write you would think he
was the you know the bluestory and then
what what he actually did there was no
ideological coherence there and I think
that was probably the biggest downfall
because he basically squandered the
largest majority of the tourists had
seen since Thatcher and also he didn't
really have any lasting Legacy outside
of Ukraine and if you look at man I
thought Ukraine became for him a very
expedient crash
he seemed to see he seemed to get on
that train to to Kiev every time the
crap was sitting I think anybody else in
British politics would have done the
same okay I can hear people shout the
name of Jeremy Corbin I wouldn't be sure
about him alas doing the right thing on
crane but ever just by everybody else
would have done okay so so I say worst
ever
you agree yeah the last hundred years
certainly all right yeah it's right
anyway you're staying with me Pat come
back a little later thank you very much
on sentence next tonight we're one of
the worst modern leaders to one of the
oldest Joe Biden uh as it said he's
gonna run for president again which will
take him to 86 by the end of the second
term is he too old and too unpopular to
run again debating that with a man who
wants to be the youngest ever president
Republican nominee candidate Vivek
ramaswami last name
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture
there's no subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
please
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to fears of organized
sensor we've just been discussing failed
leadership in Britain across the pond
polls indicated people feel much the
same way about their leaders just five
percent of Americans want Biden and
Trump to run in next year's presidential
election again but it Remains the most
likely outcome this apparent crisis that
leadership brought to mind an interview
I did with a legendary singer Harry
Belafonte who's just died at the age of
96. well there's Harry singing of course
his best known song
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
a great singer and a great performer
also a great interviewee I sat with him
at CNN about 10 years ago and he told me
about meeting Dr Martin Luther King and
what remarkable leader both King was and
also Robert F Kennedy of course was the
brother of John Kennedy and both of
course got assassinated and he went on
to say this about what we lacked in the
world today
I think we've got a lot of guys are
politically smart they can play the
chess game but they have lost moral
compass and it is the absence of that
moral vision and the absence of that
moral courage that I think we suffer
from
well joining me now is Republican
presidential candidate Vivek ramaswamy
it's a bit like I thought that was a
fascinating quote that I've found when I
look back at my interview with with the
great Harry Belafonte about the lack of
moral courage in modern leaders and that
really I felt resonated with me because
there's a lack of moral courage in our
leaders
it resonates with me Pierce too it's
part of why I'm in this race is it's not
just a case for stylistic differences to
say that hey that's just the way to be I
happen to believe that is the way to be
morally courageous I want to look my son
in the eye and say I want you to grow up
to be like him whoever's in the white
house and I can't have said that in good
conscience for a very long time probably
since Ronald Reagan but I also think it
allows you to be more effective because
look I'm taking our America First agenda
further than Donald Trump did but I'm
going to go the distance by not making
it so easy for the other side to come
after me and I think you can go further
when you're doing it from a place of
moral conviction moral Authority and
first principles not just Vengeance and
grievance and as the first Millennial
ever to run for president as a
republican I think that'll actually
hopefully be able to set an example that
the next generation of Americans is
actually hungry to follow even though
they may not admit it openly I mean I've
been on the show a few times and I love
your energy your dynamism and the
different way way that you think about
stuff I think it makes you a very
interesting candidate even if according
to the polls at the moment you don't
have a lot of Hope of winning the
nomination but you may well shape the
eventual winner I don't want to you know
downgrade your chances but as things
stand it looks so it's plenty of time to
go though so we'll see you today I'm not
writing you off I'm just saying it's
going to be a tough Mountain but what's
my point but my point is when I when I
see your Youth and dynamism and energy
and I compare it with Joe Biden for
example who is going to be 82 at the
next election which he wants to contest
and then 86 by the end of it and you
know people over here think my god
really Joe Biden's going to run again
it's like you can barely swing a
sentence together and it that his rival
may be according to the polls of the
moment Donald Trump who himself is
heading towards 80. uh again people
across the pond go well hey there must
be better candidates in America than two
you know one oxygen area and one heading
that way a one who's just gotten the
criminal indictment and one who looks
like he's senile
well I'll say a couple of things I mean
first of all I'm about in the polls
where Donald Trump was in 2015. when he
came down the escalator so I think that
I think that there's room for this race
to mature and that's why I'm in it both
Trump and Biden are over twice my age
literally 2X and Biden by uh by margin
and then some but it's not even just an
age question Pierce I think that you
want to see the essence of what's
happening with Joe Biden it's not that
his cognitive deficits are a bug they're
a sort of feature actually because Joe
Biden isn't really running for president
in this country in a technical sense he
is but he's not actually running it's
the managerial class that has propped up
President Biden as a sort of front man
as a sort of kind of The Wizard of Oz
sort of a hollowed-out husk a symbol
that they're using to advance their
agenda so measured against that it makes
a lot of sense him having cognitive
deficits is an advantage much like
Senator John Federman being able to
mentally function effectively in the
Senate that lends them to be more easily
captured by the managerial class the
true people that run the show in
government in the managerial bureaucracy
so it's a little bit more cynical than
just saying why do you think yeah it is
but I do think the main reason Joe
Biden's running again is because he
thinks his opponent is going to be
Donald Trump but he's pretty certain he
can beat him now I don't think he'd feel
that way about any other Republican
candidate I mean you could put it pretty
well put anyone else up against Biden
and they'd have a better chance the
latest polls for example show the
governor of Florida Ronda santis in a
matchup against Biden would beat him
nationally and is leading him in I think
five of the six main uh potential
Battleground States Trump conversely in
the same poll of polls is seen to be
losing to Biden across the board so it
looks to me like Trump had this weird
Stranglehold over the Republican party
that the GOP can't shed and that may
drive him to win the nomination that's
why Biden wants him to be the nominee
and that's why Biden's running again how
do you stop it as a party
I don't think that he has that
Stranglehold Pierce that's what the
polls say now but you gotta skate to
where the puck is going every time
pundits make this mistake anything
before that first debate in August is
literally irrelevant as it was in the
last cycle in 2015 as it has been in so
many cycles and what I see when I travel
rooms across the country I mean I'm only
eight weeks into this race I'm already
kind of in a fourth position or fifth
position in almost all the recent
National polls as somebody who came in
as an outsider what it shows is people
in the Republican base are actually
hungry they're hungry for America first
as an agenda but what I tell them is
America First does not belong to Donald
Trump he didn't invent it it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to the people of
this country so this is a long process
for a reason okay okay when you're
standing on that Podium at that first
debate next to Trump you know what it'll
do it'll come after all of you have you
thought about a nickname he's going to
give you yet because he hasn't actually
come up with one yet well actually he's
been calling me young Vivek ramaswami
recently uh so I'll take that I am young
there's a lot worse than that coming but
he's going to come for you are you ready
for him I've got a thick skin you might
have seen me on with Don Lemon last week
I go to the left I take a lot of arrows
I don't think those people I don't think
Donald Trump is going to relish being on
that debate stage with me I actually
think peers if Ron DeSantis doesn't
enter this race I think Donald Trump
will choose not to be on the debate
stage with me you know if I was in his
shoes I understand that argument but I
personally think that we are a better
party than the Democrats where Joe Biden
is being protected by the managerial
class in the Democratic Party by saying
they won't have the debates I think the
debates are going to be crucial for
actually sharpening the iron of the
Republican well I agree and actually I
do think you're going to perform very
well at those debates for event because
you debate well with journalists and
like you said you went on CNN debated
with Don Lemon and that was the end of
his career at CNN so we don't we don't
hold back we don't we don't play with
kid gloves
listen I appreciate you coming on Piers
Morgan and censored it's always good to
catch up with this can be really
interesting to see how it all develops
and you're quite right when Donald Trump
first said he was running in 2015 he had
the same numbers as you so stranger
things have happened and I admire your
energy and I wish you good luck
thank you pierce appreciate that well
let's talk more about the race for the
White House now because it's oh it's all
kicking off outkick Fox Nation host
Tommy later and Lauren Fox News host
Geraldo Rivera join me a wonderful
double out now Gerardo you are a lot
older than you look and I mean that as a
compliment in that you'll need you'll
quite hear Joe Biden's age but to me
you're you're Joe Biden's real problem
because you are full of 40 year old vim
and energy and dynamism and mental
acuity all the things we would want in a
president of the United States Joe Biden
is only a little bit older than you but
doesn't have any of it that's my problem
with him
well uh
uh the President Biden is eight months
older than I am piers
I'm hearing a little mix minus so if I
seem senile it's because I'm hearing
myself in an echo no no problem
the
uh you know and Mick Jagger is uh just
three weeks uh younger than I uh you
know I don't feel uh that uh that his
age is in any way compromising him I
think that because uh he's I have hair
uh I have a narrow waistline that's
where you get the uh the impression
maybe false impression that I physically
am different than our our current
president uh but I I think that he has
demonstrated in the last two and FPS I'm
not a fan I'm not a Democrat I'm a
republican uh but I I do believe that he
is much more with it than his critics
give him credit uh and I also believe
fears that uniquely this election will
be about abortion rights uh the Gen
ziers uh here in the United States the
uh you know the progressive side of the
democratic party they are more motivated
by Reproductive Rights and Roe versus
Wade our uh Supreme Court decision that
epic decision that avoided the constant
institutional right after 50 years for a
woman to have a legal abortion when and
where she chooses I think that that will
be it'll be an issue like that that
issue it'll be I want to be very
specific I believe this will this race
will be about abortion Biden is for
abortion rights Trump is against
abortion rights that's the Dilemma the
Republicans have they are a minority we
are a minority when it comes to that
issue in the country and I believe that
that more than his stumbling fumbling
Frailty will uh will all right decide on
the election I imagine you couldn't
disagree more with what you just heard
well I do agree on the abortion
discussion I do agree that that is going
to be a hurdle for republicans and I've
been very open about that we need to
have a more moderate message on that
topic but going back to what Geraldo
said about we underestimate Biden's
cognitive ability let's cut the BS I
think we've all listened to this
President enough in the last couple of
years to know that this man is clearly
on a cognitive decline which is why he
didn't announce his re-election in front
of people he put out a Twitter video at
6 a.m this is a basement president and
again he will be a basement candidate
the American people deserve more than
that however as Republicans we cannot
underestimate Joe Biden because the
Democrat machine is so strong and so
well oiled that they could put a paper
cup up and have a chance at beating our
candidate if we're not smart and if we
don't get the message out about early
voting ballot harvesting and everything
else but tell me let me ask you this
their advantage let me ask you this
Tommy I've just written a column for the
New York Post in which I say there's
only one One Way Biden wins if he
genuinely runs again as he says he's
going to next year and that's if Donald
Trump is his opponent that's the only
way the Republicans lose that election
and I recommend that they should go for
someone 30 years younger Ronda santis
governor of Florida is a proven winner
he was the big standout winner of the
midterm elections do you think Tommy I
mean can the Republicans actually win
with Donald Trump I know Trump thinks he
can but do any Republicans think he can
appears you're not wrong and I agree
with you wholeheartedly unfortunately we
are at a point now where people are not
going to vote for Joe Biden they're just
going to vote against Donald Trump
because people have such a bad taste in
their mouth which I believe is unfairly
pointed towards Donald Trump but there's
too many people in this country
Republicans and Democrats who just don't
like Trump so as much as I love Donald
Trump I wish he was our president but I
don't want him to be our nominee because
I don't want Joe Biden to be my
president again and even worse I don't
want Tamala or Gavin Newsom and I truly
think before 2024 I do believe that they
will throw Biden under the bus and they
will Usher and Gavin Newsom I'm going to
hold firm to that well they might but
haraldo just to come to you on that
point they might unless Trump is the
nominee because they may think you know
what Joe Biden beat him once and he can
beat him again and Trump has proven
really since that amazing win in 2016 at
the next midterms in 2018 the 2020
election the 2022 midterms everything
Trump has touched has pretty well turned
to the opposite of gold so I to me it
would be political suicide for the
Republicans but they do seem to be
heading that way
they they might be I think that Biden is
the only person that can beat Trump and
that Trump uh will beat everyone else in
the Republican primary I think that it
will be Trump versus Biden and I do
believe that the bigger issue and you
referenced it a bit there Piers is the
number two on the Democratic ticket
Kamala Harris uh God bless her a senator
attorney general uh uh you know a
wonderful record has been a a woeful
vice president in terms of the Public's
reaction to her I've got nothing
personally against her but she was named
for instance the borders are our
Southern border
that and she she barely bare yeah she
barely showed up at the border I went
and and went on to something else I
think that she is uniquely disliked
right now I mean I don't know maybe she
can turn it around but I think that if
the Republicans focus on the vice
presidential candidate on Kamala Harris
maybe they may get uh some traction out
of that well I'll make a prediction
you can play this clip back in two years
time but if the nominee is Trump I say
Biden will beat him and if the nominee
is DeSantis I say the Republicans have a
big win now you can take that to the
bank
[Laughter]
great to talk to you both thank you both
very much indeed
okay well coming next on uncensored
transgender swimmer Leah Thomas calls
out women for speaking up for women well
debate that
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
yes
last week ever back out my great pack
I'm gonna play a little clip from Leah
Thomas she's the person the transgender
athlete at the center of this huge rail
about trans athletes and women's sport
and she's gone on the attack about those
that criticize the fact that she is a
former biological male who is now
decimating female swimmers in the pool
she thinks she's transphobic do you even
suggest that take a listen
you can't really have that that sort of
half support where you're like oh I
respect you as a woman here but not here
they're using the guys of feminism to
sort of push transphobic uh beliefs and
I think a lot of people in that camp
sort of carry an implicit bias against
trans people but don't want to I guess
fully manifest or speak that out and so
they try to just play it off as this
sort of half support
Esther this is infuriating it made my
blood honestly if you criticize Leah
Thomas ubother is a six foot four inch
biological male now identifying as
female but with no surgery to change
anything if you criticize you apparently
are transphobic and I don't listen I
don't think the surgery makes much of a
difference although I would say there's
a much more it doesn't a pool probably
reduction in your physical size well I
would say that if you if you go the
distance actually chop off your penis I
can I can assume you're serious about
this um so that's one thing but it's the
audacity to say that you're a fake
feminist because you don't want a
biological male to effectively
disintegrate women's sports and anything
to do with women so Kevin for me this
whole debate would be so much less
incendiary if people like Leah Thomas
didn't say things like that just to
enrage women yeah there are people on
both sides who just really speak rather
rather the robot really about the other
side and that we saw that there look
biological sex matters in sport it's why
we have men's sports and women's sport
and that's why they know I'm happy yeah
I'm happy to say Hershey uh treat with
respect in every way but in sport okay
there is an unfair let's move to an
issue which is even more incendiary
which is a new surveys come out that
says that Jaffa Cakes these things are
the best things to dunk into a cup of
tea I've got you all Cups of Tea here
now this is not even a biscuit this is a
cake right yeah with the cake you don't
dunk cakes in tea the one you do dunk is
one I asked for and they managed to buy
five different biscuits here without
buying the one I actually asked for
which is mcvitty's Rich tea business oh
yeah only ones you should ever dunk and
say oh we agree oh yeah and custard
creams no no no they're fantastic
Rich tea for donkeys
followed only by the digest the very
thin digestive yeah that's it that's it
really nothing chocolate you'd ever go
into tea you're right Jeff jaffa cakes
don't
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it what that one too
[Music]
thank you
actionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're too